Speaker 1: Let's get to the mail bag for the
week.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com
if you have something to say.
Hopefully it doesn't have to be positive,
but maybe at least thought provoking in some
way or interesting or had enough something
Dottie wrote in to me.
And this one came in via Facebook.
And Dottie said, You're an idiot.
First word is already wrong.
As you know, almost a requirement in these
emails that you use the wrong you are.
You're an idiot.
You don't talk about our president that way.
President Trump is our president and he said
exactly what he should have said.
Those people that are in jail are not criminals.
They're innocent people that were put there
just to show face in the Democratic Party.
So don't talk about President Trump.
He's exactly right and he's not confused about
anything.
You're the one that's confused.
Examine your own mind.
Open up your mind and realize what you're
saying.
He's a smart ass and the best president we've
ever had.
One sentence, I guess.
No punctuation, complete cult.
Commitment.
To Donald Trump and MAGA Trumpism.
This is someone who will vote Trump in 2024.
So if we're thinking about what is the math,
what is the what is the constituency that
takes Trump down, it probably doesn't include
Dottie, and that's okay.
That constituency may still exist, but.
This is what we're not.
Don't even know where we're going.
This is what we're up against and it's really,
really scary.
Michael wrote in with a slightly more grammatically
correct but still factually vapid statement
called leftist hypocrisy.
Michael wrote this six January I'm sorry,
the January six, quote, Rioters did not break
the law.
They were allowed in, even invited by Capitol
Police as seen on video.
They are innocent.
But you don't care because you're a Democrat.
Wrong.
You're suffering TDs and happy to jail political
opponents.
Not me.
You must have my politics mixed up with someone
else's.
You never called for antifa arrested even
though they did millions in damage way more
than the protesters on January six.
Also, people died in the end for riots.
The only death at the Capitol was Ashli Babbitt,
killed by rogue cop.
Yet you don't want him jailed.
Just walk free like nothing.
You are a hypocrite.
And it's clear to anyone who isn't a Democrat.
So this is crazy.
But a few important points, I think to mention.
I have never said if someone committed a crime,
don't prosecute them.
I have never said that.
I have always said if there were crimes committed
during an Antifa demonstration or a Black
Lives Matter demonstration, no matter who
did it, whether it was a member of Antifa,
to the extent that there's membership, if
it was a part of whoever, if there is evidence
that a crime was committed.
Charge the person.
I don't care about the affiliation.
I also know that the 700 defendants from the
Trump riots are obviously not innocent.
And in fact, courts and juries have adjudicated
them guilty in already dozens, if not hundreds.
I don't know where we are in the process of
all those cases.
I am not happy to jail political opponents.
In fact, I am against it.
I don't believe in jailing people because
we have different politics.
I do believe that if you want to make an argument
that pretrial detention in this country is
a problem, by the way, it's an argument I've
been making for a decade.
You are the one who has to be consistent,
because all of these right wingers only now
care about pretrial detention for defendants.
They never cared about it before.
They never cared about it when it was people
with whom they disagreed politically.
So they are the hypocrites, not me.
Better marketing.
Spencer wrote in about the left and better
marketing and says, David, do you think the
left needs to market and message their policies
better?
Medicare for All doesn't seem to be driving
people to the polls.
Remember, more people supported gay marriage
once it was called marriage equality and more
people supported gun control once it was called
ending gun violence.
Medicare for All seems like a government program,
like a welfare giveaway.
Maybe call it guaranteed health care or something
similar.
Beth Spencer.
So there's two questions here.
The first is about the best name for a health
care system where everybody has coverage.
I, quite frankly, don't care what you call
it.
I'm totally open to the idea that Medicare
for all may not be the best term.
I don't know about guaranteed health care.
Who's guaranteeing it?
I don't know.
But just focus group it.
Let's figure out what the right term is.
Does the left need to better market and frame
1,000%?
And I've talked about this so many times before.
The left loses so much on framing.
We've talked about pro-life.
We've talked about tax relief.
We've talked about, you know, medical freedom,
but used in a completely dishonest way.
Yet there are so many examples.
The left does need help on that.
It seems like a worthwhile thing to do to
put some money into, quite frankly.
Fritz wrote in and Fritz is happy.
Because there's finally a progressive voice
on the radio.
Fritz writes, Hello, Mr. Pacman and Crew.
I grew up and still live in rural Indiana.
I currently live in Goshen, Indiana, which
is a micro city.
I've been to Goshen.
Radio is still a major part of rural life
in Indiana.
It's free and people spend a lot of time in
their vehicles.
Yes, we have public radio and it's okay.
But there's so little testosterone on the
public stations in comparison to the bombastic
crap on the right that leftists are just saying.
Really, arguments seem weaker on enthusiastic.
Please note, I am not saying you're some sort
of super macho man for progressive values,
Fritz.
I don't think anyone thinks you're saying
I'm some kind of macho man.
I don't know that that's necessarily a correction
that was necessary, but at least you're willing
to be argumentative.
And quite frankly, it works in this area.
You're willing to engage with them and where
they are on the radio in rural Indiana, it
will make a difference, or at least it will
stir the pot a bit.
Thanks again, Fritz.
Fritz.
Thank you.
You know, we do the radio show.
Some people may or may not know this.
We don't make any money from the syndicated
radio show.
And I'm not saying this like, oh, I have tears
in my eyes even though I'm a big, strong guy.
I'm just saying, we've decided, even though
we don't monetize radio like our income comes
from the online podcasts, YouTube, etc., we
produce the radio show at our expense.
It's a loss.
It's like a Trump business.
It's a loss because we think it's worth being
on in a lot of these rural places where there
are very few options for non right wing or
religious radio.
So we're doing it and we're going to continue
to do it.
Irv wrote in Irv says, David, it always amazes
me when right wingers call you a communist
insultingly.
Yet are devotees of Tucker Carlson and the
Fox News cabal who idolize the most communist
country and its leader, Putin.
In fact, so much so that they are featured
in virtually all of Putin's propaganda campaigns.
Aren't they the Communists?
They will never accept this analysis.
Ever, ever, ever.
They will say it's not about defending communism.
It's about the left has a vendetta against
Russia for no reason or what.
They will squirrel their ways out of it.
But it is interesting that many of the people
that Trump was most impressed by are from
countries that don't exactly have market economies
Russia, North Korea.
We've seen it all.
Good luck convincing them.
Sam wrote in about the death penalty and says,
David, I have to disagree with your views
regarding the death penalty.
It is definitely true that many people have
been convicted incorrectly where the evidence
is circumstantial, no death penalty is warranted.
But when you have mass murder, I assume they
mean mass murderers like John Gacy, Jeffrey
Dahmer and mass school shooters like Nikolas
Cruz, where there is no contradictory evidence
there should be executions.
These people serve no function and are of
no value to society.
To the dismay of the victims families, Nikolas
Cruz was just recently sentenced for life.
Perhaps if your daughter had been one of his
victims, you would have a different point
of view.
This is so important.
Sam is not wrong.
If my daughter had been a victim of one of
these school shootings.
I might have a different point of view, but
that would be out of a desire for revenge.
And we shouldn't have a justice system based
on revenge.
So Sam is actually making my point.
Which is.
That is not a good justification for the death
penalty.
The fact that if I was in this situation,
I might want revenge by saying kill them.
It wouldn't make it any more.
Right.
It would just mean I want revenge.
So super interesting.
And I think Sam not making the strong point
that Sam thinks he or she is making a rod
wrote in about Trump sweating and says, I
believe that Trump is sweating because he
may be diagnosed with ADHD, which is treated
with Ritalin and sweating as a possible side
effect.
This fits his profile well.
If it is true that Trump is medicated for
ADHD, that medication was not revealed in
the medical release about the medications
that Donald Trump takes.
Now.
Would it be a big shock if Trump had hidden
elements of his health record?
No, it wouldn't, because he put something
out claiming he's six three and weighs £239.
And we all know that that's not true.
But as far as the record is concerned, Trump
is not on Ritalin and not being treated for
ADHD.
Write in info at David Pakman dot com if you
have something to say.
Questions are welcome.
Comments are welcome.
Demands for corrections when they are accurate
are welcome as well.
We will see you on today's bonus show.
We're off Monday in observance of the Christmas
holiday and we will be back on Tuesday.
Will see everybody then or on the bonus show.